[Music]
in fight for me news submitted by
European Joe a woman allegedly
manipulated two minutes of fighting to
that oh [ __ ] in order to win her love
oh he suddenly read the story already
it's the one what that kid nature guy
this one right accent blended dong
so this 35 year old mother of three oh
yeah and she's still got people fighting
over her what hey okay there is okay
when I was in my Spanish class like a
decade ago there is a girl I thought was
my age she was only like five years
older than me and she had three kids and
had a grandkid
and a grandkid already she was only like
32 was something like that and I was
yeah I was like how she's like well I
have a kid in 14 and their kids like Oh
cuz you do not look like from what she's
not look like she had three kids and a
grandkid and then two Jim being a
grandma 31 yeah well she did it the way
of nature intended I mean you wanna go
with it yeah that's shocking a 14 year
olds overall like back in a day would
pop out kids yeah like I'm talking about
like even some kind you give it a 2 and
a 3 here's what I'm saying
that was the whole thing the whole thing
well that's why she looks so cute she
keeps having kids cuz guys can't resist
that's when I like was in causal her if
she wanted a fourth one no I didn't get
that why I would see like Shia [ __ ] when
I was like first out of college but yeah
like I understood it I was like oh yeah
I can understand how somebody will be
like it I'm not pulling out I'll start
another family that was weird because I
was almost the age of her um her oldest
like that cuz I was like right in the
middle of those two she was five years
older I don't remember what her age was
it wasn't it was like coin I think I
know if it was in college years I
wouldn't know like 22 so yeah she woulda
been like the shoe she was like it that
get older than me
so I'm like that so like her kids about
to graduate like or get into high school
when a girl's fine guys get their
numbers I suck at girl ages though they
fight to the [ __ ] death
I don't exactly so the power women have
on guys it's [ __ ] cool I answer no
good old could really run the world if
they really knew how to be [ __ ] together
nature's fair cuz they get the period so
that's why it goes back and forth so her
name is asta and so she is that the
British Oh sister I don't know oh yeah
it's easy just go askin me and no wait
hold on oh no that was the other person
I don't know jus ka u s ki e and E
sounds like to sing yeah pretty cool
this cow skin anyways so she's a care
worker living in London so that's her
occupation care worker
sounds like an O I hope your nanny so
yeah welcome this is what happened she
was married to this man named Jade reais
just cost us so he's 42 years old so she
was married but they got a divorce and
during even though they had gotten a
divorce he was still being intimate with
her and they had a five year old
daughter together so he was still like
presents looking over at the tone just
[ __ ] a little bit here and there
exactly but at the time that's when this
chick she ended up getting a boyfriend
and so her boyfriend what's his name oh
thank god she loves you K these names
and the other two were Russian or
something little little weenie in London
or something I don't know but so anyway
so she ends up getting with this guy
named Andreas she married him okay
and so he thought that he would be able
to join her in London after his release
from prison
oh but their relationship ended
relationship ended when he was stopped
at the border and deported and so he was
not able to enter the UK so they don't
like criminals or felons in but through
him she met another inmate mantis and
sorry
Wow like a praying mantis sounds like a
James Bond villain yeah so that's when
asta travel to Stockholm to meet mantas
in person
and Swedish gangster huh did you bring
my rubies so two weeks later
mantas joined her in London but then
that's when the ex-husband found out
about him and like so you're telling me
there could have been a three-way man
fight but one couldn't get there yep
when she had manipulated both men and
convinced them to fight for her so they
weren't gonna do it in the first place
oh they're just chill they could have
been like hey bro oh you [ __ ] her too
okay cool no it did turn out that the
ex-husband was very very jealous so he
was like you that ex-husband was like
kind of bumping heads with the new guy
she thought - [ __ ] I'm asking
so then these two men they ended up
having this confrontation just two or
just a couple days after he had mantas
had arrived she's mine no she's mine
she's mine
do alien princess know she is mine
they're kind of French there I don't
know what they sound like actually I
never heard of Lithuanian accent so asta
or US or whatever reportedly asta so she
told a close friend that the two men
were going to battle to decide who would
win her affection it's so funny about
this close friend is [ __ ] telling the
world what a close friend because she
she told man says to use serious
violence against her ex-husband and so
he listened oh my god damned hit her
ex-husband 35 oh holy [ __ ] he's an
ex-con right oh that makes sense though
yeah that dude knows out of jail fighter
what do you think is like she's like
[ __ ] that's not what I met dude so
that's the baby yeah yeah the baby daddy
she should have been more specific
cuz she's all like use a lot of violence
cool I just wanted you to teach him a
big lesson not kill the [ __ ]
no she wanted him dead oh oh I mean
that's what it seems like because after
she Mantis killed him to him she
harbored him in her home but then
eventually that must turn her on though
he was apprehended by the police and he
admitted to killing the ex did she go to
jail too ya know cuz I was thinking like
it'd be the most genius plan she wanted
both dudes gone yeah so all you have to
do is get one guy to kill the other guy
and then this guy goes to jail and then
BOOM to get both dudes gone she's uh
she's on trial but okay so she's yeah
you [ __ ] up going in the same
direction
why do you brother they look like
brothers did you look related they're
perfect extras for like Eastern European
you always see you just need a leather
jacket they look like the guys like UFC
fighters or some [ __ ] to you like yeah
so this is the guy that killed this guy
oh the mug shot on the right is so smug
well that dudes just going back like
like yeah yeah
damn was [ __ ] crazy oh yeah feel
exactly the guy who got killed like it
seemed like he had to the sweeter the
tomb they both look gangsters oh and by
the way um the new guy was 25 hoosh so
it's a 35 year old girl 42 year old
ex-husband 25 year old boyfriend
mmm she is a black widow
thank God the guy the other guy got
reported yeah well he would have been me
yeah do you think you saw that he was
like I dodged a bullet there holy [ __ ]
he's the one that's technically
currently married with her I guess so he
wins at the end oh I guess so I could
still write letters to each other or she
saw him thank you for getting the two
out of your life now we can spend the
less of our lives together but the oh I
didn't even have to be in there until
she got him after the guy she [ __ ] her
friend that she that he introduced her
from jail he met she met dude that's
some gangster ass [ __ ] that's a
different world man like like a GTA game
yet the rainy names the world
well he's yeah where the Mantis is from
Stockholm analyst way me and men the
Swedish gangster was the guy that she's
married to mmm-hmm the one that's been
getting the wrong yeah that's a crazy
twisty turny type of thing there's so
many triangles laid on top of each other
hey I've heard of those same triangles
in Vietnamese circles as well
oh really yeah I Vietnamese gangster
circles where I can believe that
yeah girls make the guys do crazy [ __ ]
and they get into fights at the club and
people get stabbed and then yeah it's um
pretty creepy I feel like this is a
common thing that goes around in the
gangster world yeah thank God I'm not a
part of that world
mmm-hmm you know it's crazy they were
only divorced for
six months before he died whoa so all
this [ __ ] happened six months in six
months what a roller coaster she got
remarried within those six months and
then hooked up with his friend in six
months and then was involved in a murder
at six months she's good at falling in
love she's good how passionate I must be
though yeah like would you rather have
six months of intense passion and then
you die or not have it at all some
people's lies man he'd be like yeah you
know what I want to do man what if what
if it's like that intense though well
you're like you know what there's
nothing else to live for because this is
so intensely passionate that afterwards
life just sucks I get any more for the
20-year old guy but the four-year-old
guy did he agreed to the fight and just
lost the stabbing or did the guy like
murder he came to 40 something year old
he was the one that kind of like
instigator sort of the ex-husband was a
very jealous man
so that friend that I brought up told
the wife the yeah the the chick like you
should not have your ex-husband meet any
of these guys are [ __ ] because he's
really [ __ ] jealous she could be the
leader of a gang with her manipulation
tactics but she doesn't all dudes to
squandering her talents yep story it
could be all these guys that loved her
like the reversed pimp you know how
Pampa like has all those girls that love
them banana yeah but she could reverse
pimp it but she also sucks cos got kids
but yeah but she's also stupid because
she makes them fight each other instead
of work together yeah
[Music]